il préfère la course une course un peu
spécial unique en son genre
en effet nous avons pensé qu'il était
injuste puisque le cyclisme était à
l'honneur que le triporteur demeure
malgré darry cowl un sport obscures est
méconnue alors donc ce soir course
unique de très porteur je ne veux pas
vous en expliquer les péripéties parce
que le temps ne presse
et vous allez comprendre très bien dès
que nos garçons seront partis vous
monsieur vous représentez compiègne
voilà en clair et vous avec le maillot
olympique et 1m flamboyant et jaune
vous êtes montauban alors messieurs vous
vous connaissez votre parcours tracé sur
le sol indien
mais dieu s mamadou de s'écrouler vient
de s'écrouler les tribunes et que doit
avoir un nouvel tout de suite une très
bonne que vient de s'écrouler avec je ne
sais combien de personnes
bénévolement de toute façon que tous les
gens restent en place ça ne sert à rien
de s'affoler peut-être après tout n'y
at-il pas d' y avait beaucoup plus que
pour les coques que de mal
mais dans mes restaurants toute façon le
service des bienfaits ce qu'il fut un
sacré on va chercher immédiatement deux
extrêmes qui sont effondrées de réaliser
vous même volume à l'antenne mais cela
s'est passé les séries donnez-moi
l'antenne s'il vous plaît simone garnier
chez les spectateurs
nous allons vous donner des nouvelles
c'est un accident malheureusement
absolument d'imprévisible j'espère qu'il
n'y a pas de blessés on nous allons vous
tenir au courant
dans les circonstances actuelles je dois
vous dire que le jeu des triporteurs ici
me paraît pour l'instant assez déplacé
tant que nous saurons temps qu'une somme
va exactement que finalement il ya plus
de peur que de mal mais néanmoins le
match doit continuer c'est pour ça que
je rentre ensuite l'antenne à montauban
à vous les inciteront d'abroger couderc
et bien je voudrais savoir alors dit